Якщо священник не активіст, то який він священник?..
Як на мене завдання священника - не тільки бути тим, хто вчить, але також вчитися і від інших.
Мене звати отець Іван Городицький. Я народжений у Дрогобицькому районі.
Поступив до семінарії у Львові, навчався протягом семи років. Був дияконом шість місяців.
Священником в Україні я був тільки один місяць. Після цього мені запропонували поїхати до Франції.
І я був у Франції рік та вісім місяців.
Я служив для української громади в Парижі.
Коли ти живеш у Парижі, ти бачиш Париж із середини. Я розумів, що все-таки як би там добре не було, але краще є дома.
Тому так, я ухвалив десь смішне, але важливе рішення у своєму житті та сказав, що я вертаюся додому.
І буду пробувати все те, що там побачив, реалізувати в Україні. Чи в селі, чи в місті - куди б мене Бог не закинув.
Я не знав, що я буду служити саме в цьому селі.
Вітаємо в мальовничому селі Ладанці. Шкода, що краса його прихована зараз під снігом, але вже як є.
Коли я приїхав уперше, було дуже холодно. Скажу так, у Франції я трішечки відвик від цього холоду, оскільки там зима тепліша.
І коли ми почали служити богослужіння, інколи бувало так, що і руки синіли.
Тому я собі поставив найперше за мету і намагався це пояснити своїм парафіянам,
що ми не можемо молитися в холодному храмі, бо ми не думаємо про молитву, але думаємо про холод.
Ми почали робити реконструкцію в храмі. А потім якось ухвалили спільне рішення, щоб зробити теплу підлогу.
Завдяки нашому хору, який трохи їздив зі мною за кордон з концертами, ми змогли зібрати 36 тисяч гривень у Польщі.
(Хор співає)
І на сьогодні, дякувати Богу, ми маємо нагоду молитися в теплому храмі.
Я можу сказати, що я себе почуваю ладанчанином з крові і плоті.
Можливо, я не народжений тут, але я дуже сильно глибоко переживаю життя і долю цього села і храму.
Якщо ми говоримо про благополуччя храму, воно супроводжується благополуччям цілого села,
тому ми як парафіянська спільнота намагаємося дбати не тільки про розбудову храму, як споруди,
але десь також про ті чи інші речі, які покращуватимуть життя наших ладанчан безпосередньо в нашому селі.
Ми провели центральне освітлення. Старе воно було, може, ще за Радянського Союзу, не пригадую.
Потім його не стало, і ми запалились ідеєю, що його все-таки потрібно зробити, з парафіяльною громадою.
Тобто ми писали проєкти, займалися пошуком фінансів. Також ми почали робити із селом сортування сміття.
Я не ідеалізую, що його сортують всі. Знову ж таки, є категорія людей, які не є прихильниками цього методу.
Але тим не менше є ентузіасти, які зі мною підтримують такю політику.
Люди міняються, люди допомагають, люди відгукуються, приходять на допомогу, дещо там роблять.
Ви вже бачили що в храмі замінили дах, там багато наших людей  працювало, наших чоловіків. Вони вклали силу і час.
Сприйняли ніби нормально, добре, бо почали ті пляшки сортувати вдома. І тоді несуть до тих ящиків. Там пластмаса, там скло. Так, ніби всі згодні.
DW: А навіщо він так робить, як Ви думаєте?
Ну, я знаю навіщо…. Думаю, добре вихований. І був за кордоном, щось бачив і хоче нас того навчити.
Він до нас приїхав, як ніби з неба злетів, знаєте… Я вже маю 84 роки. Такої людини ще в нас не було.
Він така людина, що куди би не пішов, що би не зробив, все так від душі. Він іде дорогою і кожен папірець підніме.
Посміхайтеся всі!
Це наш Народний дім. Тобто він був раніше молочарнею, був збудований, здається, якось казали десь у 30-х роках.
Потім за Радянського Союзу це був клуб. А вже потім став Дім культури або Народний дім, як ми його зараз називаємо.
Тут є величезна зала, в якій відбуваються різного роду концерти. І є також офіс.
Ми хочемо зробити ще відкриту терасу, щоб можна було дивитися на село, попиваючи каву.
І також буде ще читальня або якась інша зала на другому поверсі.
Ми також намагаємося зробити молодіжний центр у підвалі. На сьогодні ми вже зробили теплу підлогу,
закупили вікна та двері, але ще шукаємо зараз фінанси на те, щоб зробити систему водовідведення і продовжити роботу.
Отець Іван Городецький живе у нас десь орієнтовно 3-4 роки. До цього в нас часто мінялися отці.
А як прийшов отець, село корінним чином змінилося в кращу сторону.
Пане Василю! Дякую за сходи!
Він хоча отець греко-католицької громади, але він об’єднав дві громади до одного цілого - як греко-католицьку, так і православну.
Хоче, щоб у селі все було і швидкими темпами. Все щоб було гарно: відбудована церква, все в церкві було, в Народному домі.
Для мене як храм важливу роль відіграє в селі, так і культурні аспекти села…
Ми писали проєкти, трохи люди долучаються самостійно, трохи жебраємо.
Наприклад, на дах, на вікна, на двері ми отримали фінансування з Нідерландів, від двох фундацій.
Дякувати їм ми отримали 11 тисяч євро на це все. Ви розумієте, ми би такі гроші не знайшли.
Ми загалом написали десь шість проєктів.
Проєкт англомовний табір для дітей написали. Проєкт на сучасний інтерактивний клас-світлицю.
Проєкт на молодіжний центр маємо. Проєкт на народний дім.
Ця документація - це дуже багато бюрократії і дуже мало справ.
Мені вистачило того, як ми робили світло в селі, що ми цілий рік ходили, просили, молили, благали.
І кожен раз якісь були перипетії, виринали знову ж таки і знову.
Коли ми говоримо про освітлення, то 100 тисяч гривень з чимось я випросив…
І це була прекрасна історія, коли я за один вечір обдзвонив всіх вихідців із села Ладанці, які мешкають у Львові.
Ми за три дні назбирали 48 тисяч гривень від тих людей, які мешкають поза селом. У селі люди почали збирати гроші, щоб ще доробити, бо бракувало.
Я казав, якщо ми здамося зараз, то все! І тоді хотілося трохи плакати. А вже потім - плакати з радості, що в кінцевому результаті зробили.
Але це було дуже багато крові і дуже багато поту, дуже багато нервів і дуже багато зустрічей насправді.
Це будинок, який належав свого часу парафіянам нашим. І вони потім подарували цей будинок церкві.
Він був маленький. Тут було тільки дві кімнати, а потім вже з часом почали його розбудовувати.
А вже потім я займався трохи облагородженням території. Що можу, то роблю. Забігайте.
Ми є прихильниками того, щоб використовувати фактично все те, що нам Бог дарував, і переробляти старі речі, даючи їм нове життя.
Тому почали щось переробляти. Так зробили ось цей столик із старої підлоги між іншим.
Я намалював ескіз цього столику. А це - старі крісла, на які я пошив нові чохли, обтягнув їх, щоб якось увиразнити дизайн цієї кухні.
А позаду - це якраз є наше село.
Це мене так навчили свого часу знайомі.
Ви потім покажете, чим ми вас годували, так всі почнуть до нас їздити.
Фактично весь одяг, який я ношу, це моя робота.
Тут, на вішаку, всі білі сорочки шиті мною.
Натомість вишиті сорочки - це є сорочки із вживаними старими рушниками, які я просто переробляю, щоб дати їм нове життя.
З дитинства в мене було бажання бути дизайнером інтер’єру, а також священником.
Тим не менше коли довелося ухвалювати рішення, чи йти до семінарії, чи йти навчатися до коледжу, чи десь інде….
Я не знаю, можливо, це якесь Боже провидіння, або не знаю що…
Мені важко пояснити це зараз. Я вирішив тоді, що я не навчатимуся на дизайнера.
І з одного боку, мені певною мірою прикро, бо втрачаєш те, що ти любиш. Бо шиття або ще такі творчі речі я любив.
Але коли я поступив до духовної семінарії, мені випала нагода зустріти семінарійну кравчиню,
при якій я вчився і працював, розвивався і потім вже сам, скажімо, став на ноги.
Зараз ми з вами знаходимося в шкільній світлиці, яка отримала нове життя завдяки нашим зусиллям.
Якщо подивитися на ті крісла, які є тут у світлиці, то це крісла, які були свого часу просто списані.
Я обтягував ці спинки власноручно з чоловіками. Наші діти мили їх та малювали, і потім чоловіки окремо їх зварювали.
Якщо ви подивитеся на цей столик для молитви, чи ось цю трибуну для читання святого письма,
то це також було зроблено за моїм дизайном, із старих банерів з обміну валют.
Навіть не знаю, що очікувати від нашого отця, бо він завжди придумує щось нове і щось таке оригінальне.
Ми завжди чекаємо від нього чогось нового, такого грандіозного.
Він нам запропонує, ми можемо де в чому здивуватися, але ми розуміємо, що це його ініціатива, і він десь це бачив, і це добре, і ми підтримуємо.
Я намагаюся всі ці таланти, які я маю, тут дати їм життя найперше.
Як на мене, завдання священника - не тільки бути тим, хто вчить, але також вчитися і від інших.
Я не знав багато українських пісень. Коли я прийшов сюди, я зрозумів, що тут народ доволі співучий, і старожили знають багато пісень.
І захотілося це підтримувати, відроджувати і самому вчитися.
Я поставив собі за мету весь час вчити, принаймні кожного місяця по одній українській пісні все більше і більше.
По-перше, люди наші, навіть старі, ті, що взагалі були, можна сказати, забуті в будинках, почали, як-то кажуть, більше спілкуватися з людьми.
Ми організовуємо концерти. Як приїхала до нас піаністка з Голландії, то повна зала була Народного дому.
Ми в цьому Народному домі проводили традиційно Святвечір 24 грудня,
щоб людей привчати до календаря, щоб людям пояснювати, що це не є нам щось чуже.
І православна громада, і католицька громада разом спільно колядують 24 грудня.
Як він каже, щоб люди трохи вирвалися, можна сказати, зі своїх домівок,
щоб вони трохи побачили світ, який є кругом, а не тільки в себе, як-то кажуть, вдома в своєму селі.
Люди бачили, що життя цікавіше, життя триває, а не зупинилося на місці і все - на цьому крапка.
Слава Ісусу Христу! Від щирого серця вітаю Вас з Новим роком та Різдвяними святами, які йдуть до нас.
Дякую за прожитий рік. Також хотілось би попросити у всіх вас, хто буде сідати до різдвяного столу, щоб ви розпочинали з подячної молитви.
І молімося за мир та спокій в Україні зокрема.
Тому зичу всім Богом благословенного святкового столу, а відтак гарних прийдешніх Різдвяних свят. Слава Ісусу Христу!